une quarantaine d'étudiants qui sont
venus volontairement dans ce camp pour
vivre pendant une semaine une mise en
situation
deux créations et éventuellement des
startups en tout cas d'avoir la bonne
idée de beats by dr
cette semaine ils viennent de partout de
toutes les écoles ils ont des profils
très diversifiés
ce qui correspond en fait à une bonne
équipe pour une entreprise donc au
départ on leur donne des thématiques
donc aujourd'hui c'est la ville de
demain donc la planète les échanges
quand il avait un certain nombre de
thématiques pour démarrer ils ont eux
même imaginer des problématiques
éventuels qui sont allés vérifier tout
de suite dehors auprès des utilisateurs
et des gens qui potentiellement étaient
aidés soumis à cette problématique
qu'ils ont vérifié que c'était bien ce
qu'ils pensent et souvent ils ont ils
ont vu que c'était pas du tout ce qu'ils
pensaient ils sont venus avec d'autres
idées
ils sont passés dans une étape qu'on
appelle idéation ils vont imaginer des
solutions des concepts de solutions qui
sont repartis vérifier avec ses
utilisateurs ou avec d'autres
et une fois qu'ils ont une idée de
solutions donc dès le mercredi ils ont
commencé à prototyper donc on a un fab
lab ils ont commencé à m'inquiéter l or
avec du carton avec du polystyrène avec
ce qu'ils avaient sous la main et ils
ont mis à l'épreuve leurs prototypes
également avec des utilisateurs voir si
c'était exactement ce qu'ils pensaient
si ça marchait pour certains ça a été
douloureux ils sont aperçus que banon
tout ça existait déjà ou ça marchait pas
comme une pensée ça n'allait pas marcher
ils ont opéré ce qu'on appelle un pivot
ils sont dix ans une autre idée y sont
partisans ont eu un moment de morale
assez bas et il a fallu les aider à
remonter à repartir sur autre chose
hier soir ils ont tous été soumis à la
pression du temps à savoir que le jury
est aujourd'hui vendredi et il ya eu
open fablab donc toute la nuit ils ont
travaillé donc ils ont mac était le
produit la solution est également le
business model comment ça va fonctionner
comment ils vont gagner de l'argent à
qui vont vendre quoi et c'est ce qu'ils
auront à présenter cet après midi grâce
à une courte vidéo
et puis une présentation de cinq minutes
devant un jury qui est constitué
d'entrepreneurs sur les a sous la main
ici notamment l'entrepreneur et
d'acteurs du plateau de saclay montcalm
à trois prix et le premier le premier
prix du jury sera un hébergement d'un an
503 avec l'accompagnement
pour mener à bien ce projet d'entreprise